My goodness! What is happening? Sam Altman has
resigned as the CEO of OpenAI. And we’ll talk
about this new AI tool too, which will be the
future of music creation, according to DeepMind.
But firing Sam Altman? Really?
Why? Everything seemed so good!
This isn’t news that you expect to hear after
a the first OpenAI developer conference,
where they announced GPT-4 Turbo, and perhaps
the first AI app store in a historic moment,
and more. And in the meantime, work on GPT-5
is also underway. They also created GPTBot,
a web crawler as a preparation for
GPT-5. OpenAI also needs to raise
more money than the 10 billion they have from
Microsoft, and work is underway on that too.
And at that moment, the news just drops
out of the sky: Sam Altman has been asked
by the board to step down. Wow. And what
happened then was absolute pandemonium.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
So, what happened then? Well,
shortly after, Greg Brockman,
co-founder and president of OpenAI also resigned.
And that’s not all, then, shortly after, three
high-level researchers also resigned. Clearly,
there are big disagreements within the
company as to how they should proceed.
What I hear is that one side would like to take
a slower, more aligned approach, while the other
is more interested in moving more quickly. It is
very difficult to say which is the right approach,
especially in the presence of this pace of
progress that you see here on Two Minute Papers.
Sometimes you see a paper that is kinda okay,
but a bit like a toy, like the DALL-E 2 text to
image AI. And then one or two more works more down
the line, DALL-E 3, an absolute powerhouse drops.
Also, that’s not all. OpenAI is a
non-profit entity, as it has been
created by its founders. But it is a for profit
entity too. Now I hear you asking, Doctor,
what is going on here? How does that happen? You
see, both are true. OpenAI is a non-profit entity
that owns the for-profit entity. And the board
of directors controls the top level. Clearly,
there are differences in opinion whether that
is a good thing or not. Is OpenAI going to
become a big trillion dollar company, or is it
going to be a small and scrappy startup with
these miracle AI systems? Differences
in opinion in there too, I am sure.
Now, in the meantime, Microsoft, major investor
in OpenAI - they are likely as surprised by
this as we are. But they have billions of
dollars invested here and they are not happy.
Especially because of what happened next. Next,
Altman said that he is ready for the next venture,
presumably with his co-founder Greg Brockman
and a bunch of researchers by his side,
I expected that an announcement will be
made about the next chapter for them.
And then, another bombshell news appears:
presumably due to the wishes of investors
and Microsoft, Altman is in talks again to be
reinstated as CEO just about a day later. So,
what could happen here? Well, option one, if that
happens, Altman would be back and would likely
be way more powerful than before. I can’t imagine
Microsoft not asking for at least a board seat, or
perhaps even an entirely new board may be created.
Or, option two, otherwise, Sam might create a
competitor to OpenAI, and I am sure there will
be investors who are eager to be a part of it.
But wait, it is still not done.
The talks have already started,
and Altman was ambivalent about coming back.
Not so sure. A key deadline was missed,
which may trigger the mass resignation
of even more scientists at OpenAI.
So what is going to happen now? Who really
knows, the story is still ongoing. So far,
this is absolute pandemonium.
There are likely intense,
and I mean intense talks in
the situation room right now.
And in the meantime, DeepMind showcased an
amazing new music creation AI where you can
do as little as just hum a song, and it
will come to life as a saxophone solo,
or any kind of music you wish. It even
creates music in the style of popular artists,
wait for it Fellow Scholars, only a few select
artists who have agreed to this program.
These will be typically 30-second song
snippets, to be used in Youtube shorts,
so you don’t have to listen to the same few songs
that dominate the market at the time. Instead,
new stuff, all the time. Really cool. Now,
interestingly, these songs will also be
digitally watermarked. It’s completely
inaudible, you will not hear anything,
but a computer will be able to detect it as a
piece of AI-generated content. Interestingly, this
watermark will also survive if someone converts
or re-compresses the file into a different
format. I am happy to hear that we are starting to
figure out how to mark AI-created content on the
internet. For music and images, there is already
great progress on this, loving it. Once again,
the papers that you see here in these videos
are coming to life. What a time to be alive!
Note that the sources for
hopefully everything that I
said here are available in the video description.